I feel like no matter where I turn
there's just stress after stress and
problem after problem which is obviously
adulting
no one warned you about this when you
were young sorry kids is Vegas on track
no nothing nothing's on track yeah
nothing's on track because there's like
you know a global supply chain of course
yeah I can't get anything done on time
no I get it it's a nightmare the goal is
to open maybe 50 or so stores I think we
need to see how you know opening the
first three go this year
it's a nightmare
on track yeah terrible and also we want
to get it right definitely
should be trigger happy I'm done with
that work is typically my release
because my house is so stressful there's
just so much going on I like to get out
and go to work and just distract myself
but right now getting the store up and
going it's so stressful